hello everyone and Merry Christmas
everyone sorry about no videos yesterday
but we will more than make up for it
today as the world the rapid and blitz
championship starts in Moscow today and
this is a game from the chess 24 a
Bandra blitz session where a Magnus
faced all it is a fir OSHA and if your
OSHA will be playing at the world rapid
and blitz championship so we can pretty
much expect the two of them to have a
clash over the board as I'm expecting
Alisa to do really well on both
tournaments especially in the blitz one
he's a extremely strong player in every
time format but in blitz especially
online blitz he's just a monster and
only only the top elite players are able
to to take him down and also something I
wanted to mention ali reza will no
longer be representing iran in any
championship as you can see this is his
feed h-has profile under federation you
can see it only says licensed so he will
not be playing for Iran due to some
reasons he is unable to you know achieve
his fullest potential he will now choose
a different Federation he's been living
in France for some months now so I've
been told
and he will most likely join the French
Federation so it will be quite an
improvement for that for the French team
but also I've heard some source that he
might be joining the the USA Federation
so still I don't know there is no exact
data on this but if you have any more
information you know feel free to share
in the comment section below so that
being said it's an interesting game from
the course is banned for blatant chests
24 let's check it out and see what we
what we might expect in over the board
competition although quite unlikely as
it is a wild game so ali reza with the
white pieces opens with E 4 we have d5
Carlsen again goes for his Scandinavian
and I'm very happy to see cross and
playing this as I started using this
some year and a half ago at this line
after Knight c3 Queen d6 I thought it
might be a nice surprise instead of
something like Queen Queen back to the
8th or a5 and I've had some decent
results with with this line so they're
very happy to see that it's
definitely usable d4 we have Knight to
f6 h3 and now a six black has a pretty
standard idea you want to play Queen b6
Knight f6 a6 Knight to c6 and develop
the Bishop to f5 and Castle queenside
White will most likely Castle kingside
and then it's a it's an active game for
black which is you know everything you
can hope for with a four I just
preventing further expansion and on the
Queen side also some future rook lifts
might be possible we have Knight to c6
by Magnus and Knight to f3 now we have
the ship to f5 so everything everything
the same white will have to play
something really different so for you
not to go for this setup with Bishop to
c4 and now comes East 6 just the the
bishop is now out of the cage so you can
now close the structure now we have
castles and Magnus castles Queen side
Bishop to e3 developing getting a bishop
nicely eyeing that Queen side we have h6
preparing to start expanding on the on
the King side and now there is one game
in the database where quinta e 2 was
played but here we have nice the b5 and
here just before all it has a play
tonight b5 Magnus mentioned in the
stream that he feels that it's coming he
felt not b5 coming
and although capturing the knight is
probably the strongest move and it is
recommended by the engine but for a
3-minute blitz game even even Carlson is
not crazy enough to play this against
all it is I rook is coming to e8 and now
the night and come to 85 take away the
the d7 squared from the king you can
play something like well even Queen a2
followed by Queen age 7 or some like d5
followed by Bishop d7 go after the night
so although in a class program of course
Magnus would capture the piece and
defend this but in a three-minute blitz
game he's not crazy
so he goes Queen back to d7 just gets
the Queen out of harm's way he wants to
start attacking on the Kings side he
doesn't want to accept any material and
open lines on the Queen side we have c3
now preparing to rush those pawns on the
Queen side also strengthening the center
and now g5 and Knight back to H do you
don't want g4 to come with an attack on
the night so night h2 and now that the
is away from f3 so he doesn't have
Knight to e5 to come with an attack on
the Queen now Magnus feels confident to
capture the night so it captures on b5 a
captures Knight b8 and rook to e8 now
with ideas it's it's not all that
difficult to win back the piece you just
have to make a lot of concessions for
the moment so that we have Knight to d5
across and is now centralizing the night
it's a pretty great piece also you're
just threatening Knight b6 to kick away
the rook and then white doesn't really
have anything to show for his sacrifice
piece so holiday citrate special
characters with Queen captures and now
Queen to a4 so again now the Queen can
come to a7 you can win your piece back
it's not a problem
Bishop to d3 also the Queen from a4
prepares c4 to dislodge the black Queen
from such a nice central square so
Bishop d3 attacks the rook and also
prevents c4 and he Rowley Reza just goes
on ice to g4 offers a rook to Magnus and
Magnus doesn't take it Magnus doesn't
want to see nice to f6 because it comes
with an attack on the Queen and also it
takes away the d7 square from the black
king so Queen a7 could be an issue but
here Magnus Magnus respects our aces so
much that he actually trusts him Magnus
doesn't even check Bishop captures an f1
it's a it's a free rook
you cannot go something like Knight of 6
because Queen captures and g2 is mate so
one of the one of the rare cases in
chess history where Carlsen actually
trusts his opponent but okay
after this Knight to g4 Magnus plays
Bishop g7 takes away the f6 square from
the knight so not possible anymore
and now rook to d1 pushing the bishop
back but just Bishop captures on d5 with
Queen to a3 and Magnus plays f5 now
saying what do you want to do with the
night you have to go back night h2 you
don't have anything to show for her
sacrifice piece but ali reza goes rook
the a1
now if Magnus were to capture the knight
here then you have rook captures on b8
black is still better he just hides the
King of course you cannot capture due to
mate but Magnus doesn't
doesn't want to over calculate anything
it's a three minute blaze game so just
King D seven now the night is nicely
defended with Knight e5 check the knight
has to go somewhere with Bishop
characters in the now D captures and
Knight to c6 now attacking the rook here
rook captures and e8 with rook captures
an da tendon out b3 preparing C for the
Tri win and win back some material
because now you're just down a piece and
you don't have anything to show for it
Ruby want and unfortunately is not
possible so Bishop to d3 by Magnus not
allowing c4 to come with a double attack
we've looked at d1 now and here Magnus
just played King t8 and it was in this
position unmoved 26 that man that alga
recipe Rosa resigned at the game as he
is now down a piece and well there's
nothing nothing to do there's there's no
no good move you're just gonna
consolidate move the Queen play
something like Queen for moved the
Bishop offer a trade of rooks and just
win the game that it's not even it's not
even a little bit dangerous and he's
he's up on time Magnus was over a minute
Ali Rezai was I think down to some 30
seconds so it is pointless but yeah also
Magnus said that it makes him so happy
that he defeated one of the best players
of our generation so there you can see
that Magnus really respects Alireza and
I'm very interested to see how younger
leaders I will do in the world rapid and
blaze championship which starts today
and the we are we are definitely going
to cover a lot of games so now that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it and
the information that I wanted to share
with you that holidays no longer plays
for Iran he is currently he will play
this world chess championship though in
rapid and blitz under the feed a flag I
have no idea what that means but there
we have it so I would I would also like
to thank Tommaso Bruni Mark W Simon
Sevilla Doug McNabb and Edward Baker for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon for the next five days we are
covering the world rapid and blitz
championship and then we are starting
our next big saga so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an ex
rest of the rest of your day